culpables es El veredicto contra cuatro
miembros del grupo de extrema derecha
broad Boys entre ellos su antiguo líder
Enrique tarrió por conspiración
sediciosa para mantener al expresidente
Donald Trump en el poder con el asalto
al Capitolio del 6 de enero de 2021 las
pruebas mostraron como Dominic pezola
josephen localizaron a las entradas del
Capitolio animaron a la multitud y
participaron en la violencia sin embargo
tarrió no estaba en la ciudad pero se
concluyó que ayudó a dirigir el ataque
durante el juicio que duró más de cuatro
meses los acusados aseguraron que tras
el llamado a la protesta de Trump se
negaron a aceptar la victoria de biden y
actuaron o como su ejército tras el
registro de medio millón de chats el
tribunal demostró que aunque no se
estableció un plan concreto para el
asalto si había mensajes violentos
insinuaciones de una acción contra el
Capitolio
este grupo de los hombres de verdad está
destinado a estandarizar la organización
de eventos el 6 de enero más de 1000
personas tienen causas penales abiertas
en la investigación del departamento de
Justicia sobre Qué pasó ese 6 de enero y
Quiénes fueron los responsables la
sentencia final contra los proud Boys se
sabrá a finales de mes podrían enfrentar
hasta 20 años a de prisión